welcome back to scp explained world war
ii is one of the most tragic periods of
recent history and perhaps the defining
event of the 20th century and not only
was this conflict a horrifying atrocity
that led to the deaths of 75 million
soldiers and civilians it was also a
time of immense weirdness the american
military created the ghost army a
tactical deception unit that used
tactics as crazy as inflatable tanks and
wooden airfields to distract and confuse
the axis powers they also temporarily
renamed hamburgers liberty stakes in
some places in order to avoid the german
connotations of the original name the
polish military even gave an actual bear
the rank of corporal and this bear named
corporal voytech became a decorated
military hero but enough about
scp-5464 we've got bigger fish or well
bears to fry one party in this war had
more than their fair share of alleged
world war ii weirdness the germans nazi
scientists were performing horrifying
and nonsensical experiments from medical
experiments on prisoners to attempt to
create large and ridiculous weapons
known as wunderwaffe one of hitler's
right-hand men heinrich himmler took up
residence in a castle where he and his
men allegedly performed odd occult
rituals and even the lebensborn a
deranged eugenics experiment intended to
produce a huge stock of aryan children
from ss member fathers and if all that
seems certifiably insane which for the
record it is then the stuff the scp
foundation has been suppressing will
make your toes curl we've already
covered the fact that even hitler
himself copied by stalin with the help
of sarkic wizards is now classified as
scp-2430
and held in containment by the
foundation but really that's just the
tip of the iceberg we can thank a shady
group known as the obscuracore for the
creation or utilization of a lot of
these artifacts and entities as we
discussed in our video on the immortal
hitler clone the obscure corps was nazi
germany's answer to the scp foundation
though their highly unethical methods
were much more like a racist version of
the chaos insurgency this group of loyal
occult thugs was charged with hunting
down any anomalous artifacts that would
give germany the edge it needed in the
war effort think the kind of guys going
after the ark of the covenant and the
holy grail while trying to kill indiana
jones of course seeing as germany still
lost the war in the end they weren't
exactly the best at their job but that
doesn't mean they don't have a long list
of bizarre and often dangerous anomalies
to their name starting with scp-2367
this is a device so infamous that not
even the scp foundation has been able to
fully suppress knowledge of its
existence popularly known as digloca
meaning the bell in german this device
has been a popular staple among time
travel and alien conspiracy theorists
and those theorists honestly aren't that
far from the truth the bell is a spatial
and temporal transportation device
created by the germans during world war
ii in hopes of teleporting spies
soldiers and equipment behind enemy
lines and terrifyingly the machine
actually worked and was able to
transport multiple ss officers however
there is one detail that makes digloca a
little less terrifying everything they
transport materializes several hundred
feet over the top of their intended
destinations in the case of all
transported ss officers this means that
they appeared high in the air and
immediately fell to their doom like
wiley e coyote ss officers hitting the
ground at incredibly high speeds is
always a delightful mental image as
funny and incompetent as this is there
is actually one major threat posed by
scp-2367
the scp foundation rated a number of
obscure strongholds during world war ii
as a part of an operation called
operation hammer during one of their
raids a large group of around 1400
german soldiers along with a huge number
of large vehicles and pieces of military
equipment fled via the glaca they all
disappeared through the teleporter and
according to all foundation estimates
they're likely to manifest again in 2031
they'll rain down from the sky near
berlin crushing everything below under
the weight of their own vehicles and
bodies a mobile task force nicknamed
himmler's housekeepers has been
mobilized to clear the area and reduce
all possible civilian fatalities when
this happens german engineering at its
finest right but hey let's give those
mad nazi inventors another chance to
prove themselves with the second even
bigger wunderwaffe designed by albert
speer german minister of armaments and
war production under adolf hitler it's
scp-044 the biggest artillery weapon
ever created it's a ginormous cannon 251
000 kilograms or 251 metric tons in
weight and so huge that it required two
freight locomotives at the same time to
transport it the nazis were big fans of
absurdly huge weapons whether they were
cannons giant planes or the world's
heaviest tanks almost as though they
were compensating for something but
there is one thing that makes 044
special to the point of being anomalous
it can fire literally anything when
something is placed inside the firing
chamber of scp-044
the weapon will transform into a
powerful explosive payload with its
explosive power being proportional to
the size of the objects placed inside
even crowds of people could be
transformed into deadly explosive rounds
one of the largest objects that the
foundation fired off was the
administrator's diesel pickup truck
weighing 8 900 kilograms how on earth
did the nazis ever lose with a weapon
like this on their side right well much
like so many of their other weapons it
was a victim of their own greed weapons
this big just couldn't be moved
practically and were easily routed by
less powerful but more maneuverable
allied weapons next we have another
anomalous nazi failure though this one
was intended to give life rather than
take it for once the anomaly in question
is scp-2936
a secret nazi military and research base
hidden in the cold reaches of antarctica
the place has likely been abandoned by
humans since the 1950s but there is one
entity that still rolls through the
halls on rumbling caterpillar tracks an
advanced sentient robot nicknamed the
stalmatter or steel mother powered by a
mysterious power source shaped like an
ambiguous glowing symbol on its chest
who would have guessed that the nazi
design sensibility was tacky the
stalmatter is there to maintain the
glasger barmotren or glass wombs where a
number of desiccated human fetuses are
held the intention of this base was
clear much like the lebensborn project
we mentioned at the start of the video
this was a controlled breeding program
supported by the nazis deranged
philosophy of eugenics but after the war
when the nazis attending the base
presumably fled for their lives there
was some kind of accident that destroyed
the seal of the glass wounds allowing
the amniotic fluid to leak out and
killing the fetuses inside but due to a
malfunction the stalmatter's diagnostics
were way off and it never realized that
its mission was futile when researchers
attempted to inform the machine of that
fact it simply replied the kingdom lie
on the bottoms of the glasgow motrin
they are unmoving like the dead soldiers
but zakinda are not soldiers and they
kinda are not on termination and the
chemical physical and mechanical
parameters of the glasgow modern are all
at optimal values
cephos ekinder are not dead
loves systematic kinder always
good kinda will grow strong and brave
and wise
this talmada loves a good kinder
the next anomaly wasn't created by the
germans or the obscura but it was
utilized by them it's scp-3457
a collection of strange rituals
artifacts and workings known as the
rights of solomon if the correct
artifacts are collected and the rights
are performed the executors of the
ritual have the ability to control the
distribution of magic or thalmaturgy
across the globe it's obscura's plan to
perform the right and remove the ability
to perform thalmaturgy from anyone who
wasn't of germanic descent giving them
german magic supremacy this was the end
of the infamous seventh occult war which
was the major geopolitical event that
led to the formation of the global
occult coalition coinciding roughly with
what we civilians consider world war ii
luckily through a collaboration between
the scp foundation and the precursor to
the global occult coalition the allied
occult coalition obscura was defeated
before they could complete the ritual
and grant magical supremacy for the
fatherland since the defeat of obscura
in this pivotal battle organizations
like the scp foundation the goc and
others have sworn to keep the different
artifacts necessary to perform the
rights of solomon safe and secure some
are kept in public museums as part of a
global sting operation to catch
remaining members of obscura who hope to
someday attempt the dark ritual again
some of the items remain in the hands of
scattered obscure remnants to this day
okay so arcane historical rights are a
little complicated let's hop back to
another wacky wonder waffle to cleanse
our palate something like
scp-3721
remember when we said the germans were
kind of obsessed with having the biggest
goddess guns back during world war ii
they were also apparently ahead of their
time in this regard as in 1943 they were
able to construct a fully operational
orbital cannon and an earthbound
computer bank that allowed them to
operate its strikes remotely but even
scarier than a giant orbital cannon
controlled by the nazis is a giant
orbital cannon that's completely out of
control that's right the computer on the
ground is autonomous and decides the
best time to make its strikes by
monitoring news broadcasts of current
events so if you feel like a day full of
bad news is unpleasant just be grateful
that it wasn't the day that activated
the massive death satellite looming up
above maybe the idea of land being
bombarded by an orbital cannon freaks
you out a little understandable really
maybe you'd prefer to flee to the water
for safety but you're not safe from the
germans there either and we're not
talking about them stealing your beach
chairs while you're going for a swim
we're talking about scp-4217
which was once known as the bismarck
which was a german world war ii
battleship before it was appropriated by
a giant cephalopod that not only has
giant dangerous tentacles but also has
the ability to use all of the ship's
weapons against you too
what will you think of next germany and
finally perhaps the strangest obscure
wonder waffle of all a dangerous
semantic weapon known as
scp-3878 it's a deadly word-based
infectious cognito hazard created in a
single patient zero via strict regimen
of psychotropic drugs electroconvulsive
therapy and at the conclusion of the
program trepination to create an
extremely strong anti-concept within the
subject's mind when this person is
activated with a trigger stimuli this
will begin to spread the cognito hazard
causing a lethal effect to anyone who
doesn't speak the subject's native
language fluently the first infectee
would have been german if the plan came
to fruition so all but fluent german
speakers would have been killed by the
infection it's a solid plan by which we
mean a metal gear solid plan
incidentally killing the victims of this
cognito hazard was never actually the
plan they just hoped to erase other
languages though given that the nazis
weren't exactly people of high moral
fiber we'd be willing to bet that they
were probably a-okay with killing anyone
who wasn't a fluent speaker of german
anyway and there you have it a taster
plate of the wackiest van der waals and
the sinister soldiers and scientists who
made them a reality or at least tried to
twist them to their own gain it's
honestly lucky for all of us that the
nazis during world war ii were a gang of
arrogant and incompetent buffoons
because if that weren't the case we'd
probably be speaking german right now
though if you'd like to live on the
bright side at least we'd be safe from
scp-3878
now go check out
scp-1461 house of the worm and
scp-2430 immortal hitler clone for more
terrifying wartime anomalies